kelsey grammer is here come on in how
are you yes welcome thank you
of course happy Valentine's Day yeah yes
sunk about 10 feet well we want to make
sure that we maintain our position
that's it's a power thing right romantic
are you gonna go out and do something
really romance in LA and I'm here so no
being el romantic that cannot but I I
sang to her this morning on another show
so that was that was good what you think
I sang Dulcinea it's from this show I'm
gonna do in a London Man of La Mancha
what's that mean no I know
woman oh ok I was like his dream woman
you know it's a little embarrassing
because I mean we weren't gonna ask you
to sing that song right but we were
dance missing this the cheers theme no I
was you know what I was looking for was
hopefully the score of the hms pinafore
oh wow i'd have to warm up a little more
for that so you have like a legitimately
good voice yeah yeah all right yeah yeah
you know Kelsey did of course Sideshow
Bob on The Simpsons and I was rewatching
that bit last night right no and I
couldn't believe the balls on that show
because in my mind I'm like yeah of
course I remember that moment but they
had the I would say courage to spend two
minutes of the show going like no we're
going for it we're gonna do little clips
of everything from this musical that
nobody watches the Gilbert and Sullivan
Simpsons crossover is so extraordinary I
like they did a full two minutes on it
and it was perfection we did opera - we
did was it the festool ahjumma you know
the the clown one that was great yeah
yeah at La Scala that was the whole idea
now would you show up and they would
write stuff like this knowing that this
is perfect for yours oh yeah that's you
know I mean I still I think I did one li
about a year ago and that probably still
hasn't been on air yet because there you
know it takes him about a year to put
all the animation together so I think
there's one still in the can coming but
yeah they they'll call me once in a
while and say we've got another one and
then one of the one of the last ones is
really surprised it was what about
Monsanto he was suddenly working for
Monsanto
they were having like sort of
acha dials was like women's legs you
know it was very very silly yes perfect
yeah yeah he's the guy do you did you
know when they do when they have this
Sideshow Bob episode that is a the Cape
Fear episode you know the one that we
were yeah pulling that from where it is
a Sideshow Bob episode on The Simpsons
did you know this is going to be one of
these episodes that people talk to me
about forever episode rest of my lines
the shadow through the universe evermore
I did not know but no I always knew the
character had already been pretty well
established the first time I played the
role which was I sang Cole Porter song
in a friend of mine who was a professor
in Evanston Illinois said you'll never
guess what I saw this morning it's the
next day after the first time it aired
there was a giant mural painted of
Sideshow Bob on the side of a dorm that
said free Sideshow Bob he caught on
pretty quick why did they cancel boss
that was a show it was a great show all
right no League love for right yeah I
did there was some personal stuff that
happened that made it impossible for one
of the guys who was an a very important
part of the show to come back the second
year and the guy that was paying the
money took that personally and we were
cancelled there was no way to fix her to
work around why we did work around it
for a season but then he had made up his
mind I'm killing this thing cuz it was
he was just mad Wow so at this point in
your career I mean as much stuff as
you've done especially in television as
much as you've done are you prepared
that like television is a fickle
business and there are reasons like this
that just come up and all of a sudden
this thing that was amazing is now gone
and on to the next one that's right you
know what you're not really you'd never
really anticipate it but you always
think that the knocks come in any minute
to say you know we're done right so you
know you just did you count your Alex
did you feel that because I mean you're
the beginning of you in television
really is Frasier for the most part yeah
yeah so after you go through Cheers
and then you go through Frasier like
your idea of television must be
everything you do you leave what you
want to leave
when you go Bob no you know what we
always have a I got to try to express
this the right way above there's a sort
of built-in understanding your job is
temporary no matter what your arm even
the television show it can always get
cancelled networks are fickle Presidents
and vice presidents of networks changed
all the time at the drop of a hat a
whole staff disappears one day and so
the decision-making process is out of
your hands so you have to have a kind of
resilience I guess that just says I'll
get another job oh you know I'll figure
out another angle is the resilience part
easier coming from a huge success or
coming from something that wasn't as
successful um you know I think it just
has to be sort of built in because we're
in the business of selling ourselves
yeah you learn very early on that it's
not personal even though it is you know
selling yourself I mean the first time I
auditioned a hundred times the first
year of mine so so-called focus on a
career I was 21 years old and I didn't
get a single job what's the first thing
you got Candide at the Matunuck Matunuck
dinner theater all his life summer
summer stock souther Matunuck summer
stock theater and I couldn't do that I
ended up doing Shakespeare instead in
San Diego what's the first thing that
got cancelled was it it was after uh
Frasier heard you had to cancel before I
think I've never really done a series
before before I did Cheers
so after Frasier I didn't kind of think
the next the next show I did was back to
you and we went on the writers strike
and then after that they didn't want to
keep doing it it was that a hard squall
to get because you probably never gotten
that call before and it's the first time
they tell you like yeah it was okay it
is what it was okay you know it's like
yeah okay I got it
that's why I had my heart attack then -
that was pretty interesting I just had a
heart attack I was working at Fox we
tried to get the show back into
production and that wasn't gonna happen
so I got a call from a Fox executive it
said iDEN by the way we need you to move
out of your offices it was batting a
thousand I was writing I was riding in a
cab in the back of a cab after leaving
the hospital and
Hawaii yeah things were okay you know
yeah my life turned out fine yeah a year
later I was married to a different woman
and I have three kids with her now and
you know things are really fantastic
thanks for good right now yeah yeah had
your heart attack what are you doing
I was paddleboarding stand-up paddle and
I had done that thing you know where you
go down to about 20 30 feet underwater
and you lift up a stone and walk along
the bottom of them I know I said well
it's it's it since a couple of movies
okay it actually is a real thing and
then I paddled back but you know it's
one of those things I stood up and I
felt a little funny and then I realized
oh [ __ ] I'm having a heart attack you
know that you are having are do you feel
like in the moment oh my god what if
this is it you start going through those
feelings you just go let's take care of
this right now well I was I was pretty
calm about it the only problem was there
was uh there was an hour and a half wait
for the ambulance because it's Hawaii oh
my god and that was a little bit that
was a little disconcerting I kept
thinking you know come on sure and this
guy be here by now but I was in severe
pain you are and uh that but I just kept
breathing deeply and you know to the
actors you know it's breathe try to go
with it oh but I did say as I said a
little prayer of you know don't show me
anything no funny lights no nothing yeah
yeah let's get this over with good let's
get this resolved and I got things I got
to do did you well you tempted just to
get yourself like how far was the
hospital like you have to 40 minutes
feel like I said give me a bicycle
there's somebody sitting there holding
my hand at that point they look my
ex-wife screaming at me and that's okay
but you kind of knew what England you
felt some tingling is that what happened
I felt um a dove dizzy there like a loss
of consciousness kind of yeah it's just
and then the pain kicked in yeah okay
that's what this asset that's that Wow
um do you like when when stuff like this
happens is because you brought up you
know the acting exercises and just go
with her does training for the theater
and the idea that we're doing this live
and no matter what happens we have to
stay in character the show must go on it
could be a disaster it could be the most
mundane night ever we're going to keep
doing this is that now seep in
into your day-to-day life so it's just
how I am you got to carry on yeah you
just keep going
um theatres a funny thing because it's
live
if something happens which is you know
bound to happen once in a while anyway
going with it is probably more fun than
pretending it's not happening right so
there's a weird thing that happens with
it but on a particular night in front of
well year four or five 600 seat house
like for instance the light board went
down when I was doing like college at
fall everything went dark and then I
told it's gonna be thirty minutes before
we can go again
so I said okay I'll give me a twenty me
a house light turn the house light on
and I'm gonna sit on the edge of the
stage and tell a joke so that night
became the night I told a joke in the
middle of a show then the show was booed
then we finished the show and so uh it's
more fun to come and just roll with
whatever's happening because the
audience always gets off on it yeah have
you found people getting ruder and
audiences to with cell phones and with
texting and all that stuff well you know
they do that announcement and somebody
always misses you know this somebody
always forgets and then you usually just
say you want to answer that or not and
then it's done yeah and you drop it so
it doesn't really bother anybody you
wait right did you ever worry when you
started getting I mean this is like one
of the great problems to have in show
business but when you start getting
really successful on television do you
ever start do you start to go oh you
know I theater is what I love doing
before I hope that people don't you
start seeing me as a television actor oh
yeah and I won't be cast on stage
anymore you are look great success in
television tends to pigeonhole you
that's the way it is I had that fear
when I took the job and cheers I thought
well especially in an era right yeah
exactly I maybe I'm never gonna do
another thing but you know hopefully
it'll turn into something that's a good
career and it did that was great but I
always wanted to go to theater throw out
and I did manage to do that so sometimes
it wasn't felt very well received I did
Macbeth and one of the reviewers said is
this a Fraser I see before me you know
will you pour on well not exactly no but
but still you know enough to have
everybody had to take their shot sure
right now because they didn't want to
separate and you know
nobody wanted to so there you know for a
while that's a little bit of an issue
but do you know that changed when I did
boss for instance I mean we'd quite
deliberately set that show up to put the
face in front of the camera the first
scene I appeared in was just me saying
nothing and a doctor like sort of
delivering this death sentence and then
after about Oh a minute and a half of
this bad news he just stands him says
thank you doctor and from that moment on
everybody was fine with oh this is Tom
Kane no this is not Frasier Crane right
right so that really helped out and
since then I've played a whole bunch of
these other things I'm doing this you
know proven innocent now which is he's
kind of a bad guy who might be a good
guy right misunderstood right you know
and that's that's one of those villains
with motive yeah exactly yeah with a
heart what you're doing if you doing if
you're successful on TV doesn't that
help with theatre cuz they're all
looking who can sell tickets so on
Broadway especially yeah yeah yeah and
you'll get a bit more of an opportunity
to you know be given forgiven for your
success do you get mad when you read
back none of us like bad stuff but I
mean we don't tend to read oh you try
not yeah yeah you know I just walk away
from it you know if you have a really
good friend that calls and says oh man
sorry about the reviews you think you
know what I don't need to ever hear from
you again wasn't a friend yeah why
numbers now if it's live it's hard you
have to go out and do it again like if
it's a movie or a TV show you're shot
while it's done but if you're to play
you're continuing to do yeah yeah that's
true you can kind of tell now the next
night if there's nobody there well I
guess the reviews weren't very good so
what do you do to occupy yourself when
you're not working because that's that's
the problem that I think people run into
I know it's a problem that I run into
that when I'm not working I have to go
like the the instinct right is to go and
look up your Twitter mentions look up
reviews like I just just look up there's
people talking about you I'm not doing
anything right now let me find out what
they're saying what do you do to
distract yourself for lack of a better
term got it from it's not really my
thing right I'm it may be generational
I'm you know I'm gonna
it wasn't around when I started so I
don't really think her into it yeah do
you read
I do I read a bit and I've got kids
right oh you know I'm good my reading
habits suck now because they online
everything is so immediate like I can't
sit down with a book or nice pictures
though with my finger believing your
attention span is terrible it's got a
horrible because of just this everything
is just so fast I can't concentrate
I think that's an exercise I think it's
a good idea grab like a classic novel
you know one of the famous ones and just
make yourself read it once in a while
and then yeah at first it's a little bit
too hard it's challenging but then you
get into the language and you think oh
no I love this you know it's but you
have to take the time out to do it do
you enjoy Shakespeare like I'm always
fascinated with people that can do that
because it seems like such a difficult
thing to do your task it's a real task
and then you watch that documentary
Pacino did about Richard the third oh
yeah yeah breaking it down like do you
look at a role he really breaks it down
I mean really that's an extraordinary
piece that sort of documentary the docq
drama thing you did there's something
that happens when you start to read
Shakespeare Oh usually when you're a
young man like 13 14 you read Julius
Caesar or whatever it is in eighth grade
and that's kind of where it begins
you either get it or you don't
it seems really really remote and and
removed from your experience at first
and all of a sudden you go wait a minute
that makes sense and once that happens
you know the language doesn't seem so
challenging you know and then you kind
of get through it and then as an actor
you find out that when you're performing
it if you start to apologize for
language any other it's that sort of
thing you know actors are oh for the
muse of fire and you think this is the
worst show if you if you get somebody
who understands that the power of the
word is that you actually fly through it
you drive a lot of pace suddenly it's
the first 10 minutes the audience is
certain like I can't get this and then
there's a moment where they just sort of
rise out of their seats and then they're
in the show and you think but as long as
you're playing up to the audience you'll
get them whereas those stories are great
stories and those plays that the best
plays ever written and that language is
the best language ever written online
you can find it was brando doing I guess
it was Julius his play Marc Anthony
see ya he actually did a great job and
yeah fantastic and you hear it you get
it you're like yeah that's how he really
taught like it sounded like that's how
he talks now didn't do it right well you
just know that crap yeah nonsense no he
was really good in that and yeah the
whole you know when it comes such
another that that speech he does you
just buy it you really it's it's
contemporary as hell because the
languages were universal yeah yeah yeah
have you really considered I mean I'm
every interview that that you're doing
right now to promote proven innocent is
also I feel like they're tackling on
doing Frazier stuff and and the idea
that you're oh yeah oh yeah James Corden
that you guys are meeting with writers
and yeah there's volleying about ideas
to to I am bring back for yeah there's
like a double layup first for the Fraser
idea we've been kicking it around
I'm also kicking around but the idea of
of another's had come with a really
well-known actor who's very famous
who I mean I think it's kind of a slam
dunk that will sell this show so I mean
there's another couple of shows I just
can't talk about it yet Alan Alda
well there's it it starts with an a but
but so the idea really will be I hope to
do that show and do an additional
Frazier's series on streaming like
Netflix or because it cuz they've got it
you know they they Fraser is still isn't
like the top ten on Netflix right in and
out and you interesting wow that's
amazing and so it it's likely that
that's kind of where its new home would
be that's where people are still
watching and we're just talking about
they were talking about doing a Breaking
Bad movie and they're putting it on
Netflix because so it's like a little
extra piece of material or yeah yeah
yeah do you like the idea of watching
binge watching stuff and it's so much
different than all those I have done it
a little bit we found a couple of my
wife likes this missus Mazal show and
that's really good and you know she'll
go through four or five at a time and I
think that's kind of fun hit and run
I never seen that is that based is that
based on anybody real it's about a
stand-up a woman doing stand in the
fifties think it's sort of derivative
you know like it's not any one
particular person but I mean I always
think of
damn it I'm gonna Frederick forget her
name but she was fantastic
Joan Rivers no labeling of the forever
Silverman go early earlier well the rest
Dylan Phyllis Diller there we go
yeah Phyllis Diller it's great actually
have a little painting she did but she
sent over to us called Martin guards the
castle it's like it's like a little
hairy beast hiding in a cave
why is Phyllis Diller make you a
painting I don't know maybe she thought
it was fun shitty way like what the [ __ ]
is I was just it was a nice I mean I
guess maybe she liked the show I don't
know Oh for the show yeah yeah but
Martin was the name of you know my dad
in it so maybe it just had a resonance
for her do you get tired of the Frazier
questions I mean I know it was great for
you but it was great show great show I
would never yell to curse your own
success is just idiotic yeah yeah some
guys do though oh that show yeah but
nobody ever succeeds after that right
they go on thinking like no I want to
talk about my new stuff and you never
hear wrong you know it's all you gotta
embrace the idea that you got there a
certain way you know I mean when I was
on cheers the first year I got offered
another show and I thought to myself
well this is stupid why would I do that
yeah you know these guys got me here I'm
gonna I'm gonna play out this hand ya
know and be respectful of the of the
gift they gave me so right now we're
supposed to be like a six-episode thing
it's a short arc and then they just
thought well he's funny and he makes
that [ __ ] funny that we didn't think was
funny and okay let's keep him around
great that's all more from the wire same
thing this must be a six episode oh
really yeah he was supposed to be in the
and people loved him so much that he
just stayed through the whole series
Cosco do they tell you that you were
gonna stay for longer or they just keep
writing like one more episode one more
episode the first year they did that and
they said well come back for a couple
more and bubble bond and then finally
said now we're gonna make your regular
so that was that was a good day when you
do a show that's like based around set
whether it's based around a radio studio
or the new show is in a courtroom
obviously do you start to feel after a
certain number of episodes or a certain
amount of time spent that like you're
part of that world meaning you walk into
a radio studio like yeah no I know I
know about this I gotta know it's like
if something comes up stage
after or like he's doing a show
especially if it was a stage fight they
say oh my god I just disappeared
you think no you're nuts let's do you
need to go to an insane asylum yeah
please
I want you to be aware that you're
acting when we're working okay but you
do meet actors that will come off like a
baseball movie and wear a baseball
uniform for like the next year or two
and you're like what you won't see much
of them again
how scary is it to do a spin-off because
spin-offs can be like yours a major hit
or they can be like you know after mash
that is good yeah there's there's a
certain amount of weight attached to it
that maybes fair not fair it's just you
still just got to do the show you want
to do Frasier was just a good show on
its own right with the pilot and that
that helped did you know from the
beginning like yeah this is gonna be
good yeah yeah at first that first read
was this is okay yeah yeah I never I was
on a show recently for company I never
went to the table read shows always a
fair thing of fire to fire me I'm in
this yeah what am i contracted to do
yeah I'll be there but every other is
just an option for you to fire me for
free yeah they didn't I didn't have to
go to them because I wasn't a big part
you know and I just I never want to want
Terry does it surprise you what what
people grab on to for example not just
the TV stuff but um and I don't even
know if you were aware of it or maybe
your kids became aware of it but you you
going viral for falling off a stage oh
yeah this is a video clip is comes that
guy from cheers the guy from Frasier
Sideshow Bob the guy from the stage yeah
yeah I mean it's gonna happen
I was I was doing the 50th anniversary
show for Disney at Disneyland and there
was a stage although it was spurred
though show Aladdin that they had at the
time and there were stars on the edge of
the stage which was sort of cut out so
the proscenium the stage part ended in
jagged edges on one side so I rehearse
tit with the lights on right and then
when I did the show there was just a
spotlight and it was dark so
lost track of where the start edge of
the stage was you know so I stepped off
a new hit the pointer when those stars
scraped my leg from my knee all the way
up to home I've buttocks and it was not
pretty but I finished the show and then
went to the hospital
oh you go to the hospital oh yeah Wow no
they said Mike I said this is worse than
any motorcycle accident I've seen really
yeah that's discouraging but my my I
wanted to be polite even so I said oh
dear Lord instead of you know whatever
it was great though that was it made it
anyway so like there was so much glass
right in that dear Lord thing a true
gentleman I think the thing that snapped
into my mind was when my grandmother
broke her hip mm-hmm that was kind of
the beginning of the end for her and I
thought I'd broken my hip that's
actually that's what I thought and then
I tried that tested it to see if I could
walk a little bit and I was okay and
you're like okay I'm all right
how long did it take you to get up and
get back on the stage there's about a
minute okay just kind of wasn't too long
I just had to test it do you bleed
through your pants or anything yeah so
you were a lot on your pants and wow you
are a hardcore
no no subsequently I mean you know I see
that again I can see why people think
it's funny I mean I had a friend fall
off the stage before and I had to get
good giggle when it happened right here
old right off that when Stiller what the
hell happened to Graham he realized he
was in the pit here's the thing about
stages that are so great is that when
somebody falls off you don't actually
see them fall they just just know it's
comical because it's instantly sort of
comical so yeah I certainly understand
it it was a very painful moment for me
in reality but I get the irony of shirin
funny look there's a friend of mine
named Keith Robinson and we have footage
from the comedy smell of him walking on
stage and tripping on his face for a
past a p.m. it's literally the greatest
thing I've ever seen things are fun I've
watched a banana peel you know yeah it
would never not be fun yeah exactly you
know political stuff or poignant stuff
or socially relevant stuff isn't the
same but the Stooges are as funny now is
absolutely four years ago contemporary
culture is never a good foundation
comedy because it's not Universal it's
stuck in its time so that there been
several shows that you know sort of
relied on that which you watch them a
decade later you like yeah what the hell
yeah what's this about that's not even
funny
right there's a stand-up like Lenny
Bruce very influential but his stand-up
alone doesn't it doesn't hold up the way
others guys because the times have
changed against such a coming had such a
focus on his sort of victimhood yeah all
the time that there there's it wasn't
necessarily coming from a funny place at
the end it was and yeah he's just
reading court papers right yeah I'm
sorry Lenny but you know it got a little
you just wanted people to hear it and
victimhood is boring you know I mean
everybody we've all been victimized by
something some some big product
governments never fun you know if you
get on the wrong side of that equation
it sucks that's what I mean talk about
like like a victimization and everything
like you've been on so many highs and
lows in every aspect there's life
imaginable how do you maintain right now
because right now you just say you got
the show coming out premieres tomorrow
night you're happy and your family like
everything's good right now but you know
something's always gonna happen right
and you sit there aware of that moment
and fear that moment or do you just
simply exist and go it's good right now
just be right now to do your best to
stay in the time that you're in yeah I
think I've you know we all have paranoid
fantasies mm-hmm you think oh geez
something could good that could happen
or something going on in the design guys
can subtly bite you in the ass from 30
years ago anything wait a minute
right no this is crap you don't want to
live in that place right but it's
natural to wonder about it once in a
while you know this will not always be
I'm on a good run this year we've had a
great year I miss my kids a little more
it's been so busy and my wife a little
more but you know it'll will be fine I
mean the summer's coming I'm not gonna
work during the summer I'm gonna take
some time off and we'll have a great
time I miss them more than anything I
hear something about I was gonna say
there is something about going through
[ __ ] that once you get out of it you go
oh I'm pretty sure I can survive
anything
yeah it'll be fine yeah I don't know
until you get over it yeah yeah are you
good at pulling yourself out of a spiral
yeah like there's something comforting
sometimes about wallowing it's a
had place to be but there's like that is
that weird hormone your brain releases
organization can feel right like when
you're along saying yeah I mean we don't
good very toxic when you just sit there
going on garbage is there something
comfortable about it yeah they'll joke
about lifting and [ __ ] yeah you spend a
lot of time there Jim
I certainly do yeah are you good at
pulling yourself out of it yeah yeah you
know this is a you know it's a little
corny but there's a poem from years ago
it's had a line stagger on weird
rejoicing that made sense to me you know
you get up you go yeah matter what's
going on and be thankful for what you
got for this life you know